and now it's time for the much heralded
hashtag war Louis st. Patrick's Day a
day dedicated to drinking and assuming
every redhead is Irish that's the photo
from redditor little red woodpecker of a
t-shirt featuring Scotland's national
motto yes the only problem st. Pat's
days by the time everyone's drunk enough
to start singing the only Irish song
maker remember is Danny Boy and maybe
maybe that u2 song from the Batman
Forever soundtrack you guys rumor that
one nope alright no Irish people here I
guess no Irish people but we're here to
help with a tonight's hashtag make a
song Irish examples might be uptown
drunk and me neck knee back they put
seeing me lucky charm
[Applause]
let's put 60 seconds on the clock I
begin yes sir kiss from a rose Asia yes
boy ELISA I want to River dance with
somebody
yes look gasser baby got back-to-back
DUIs alright in the pub yes boy yes sir
we famine famine baman baman yes boy
[Music]
those potato famine ring a bell fresh Oh
God
IRA Rock IRA Island yes fine
that's a Lester shape your last watch
yourself
yeah I got you I got you should any what
you mean I see us or Lester and punch to
me God hasn't girls just want to have
nine kids
[Laughter]
that Papa with a Blarney Stone yes
[Applause]